Scientists are sending a submarine to Saturn's
moon Titan to explore its alien oceans in
search for life and to possibly understand
how life began on our own planet!
Researchers are studying two main oceans on
Titan.
The Kraken Mare and Ligeia Mare.
Both of which were discovered fairly recently
by the Cassini space probe.
Ligeia Mare is less than 200 meters deep.
But the Kraken Mare, we don't know how deep
it is.
So sending this Submarine could answer a lot
of questions including the depth.
Titan might also answer a lot of geological
Earth questions, because Titan is composed
of a nitrogen-rich atmosphere… it also has
seasonal cycles, ocean waves, possible ice
water, landscape erosions, and a hot rocky
core...
Which all sounds very familiar, it seems to
have a lot in common with with our own planet,
Earth.
The goal is to have the submarine dive deep
into the oceans and look at heavy metals that
might have settled down to the bottom.
They'll use a mass spectrometer to measure
the elements and see what they’re made of.
In order to gather data, the submarine will
have to be prepared for these mysterious and
icy cold oceans on the moon.
And there are a few obstacles to that.
The pressure on Titan, for example, is about
60% more than on Earth, about the same pressure
as at the bottom of a swimming pool.
So, researchers at Washington State University
partnered with NASA to try and re-create the
oceans of Titan, but in a lab... here on Earth.
They did this by making a pressurized chamber
and filling it with liquid methane, liquid
ethane, and nitrogen gas to simulate the environment
on Titan.
Then they cooled it to about -150 degrees
C and boom a mini-Titan ocean!
Inside they were able to test possible space-going
equipment.
For example, they engineered a borescope and
a video camera that could withstand the super
cold temperatures and high pressures on Titan.
But unlike other probes, we can’t rely on
solar power for this mission, so they’re
planning on installing instead an RTG -- or
Radioisotope Thermoelectric Generator.
Basically, this sucker is nuclear.
The challenges of engineering a submarine
to head to another moon is just astronomical
to use exactly the right word.
But hopefully we're going to answer a lot
of unanswered questions about how life began
on our own planet, and possibly life in our
solar system.
For more on this submarine, check out our
sister show Space Crafts here!
Please take a second and subscribe.
Scientists know how geochemistry happens on
Earth, by the way but don’t know how the
process went from geo-chem to bio-chem.
So hopefully studying Titan could tell us
a lot more about how we got life on our planet.
Thanks for watching.